pediram né
um momento vou dar-vos de dois em dois
momentos no torna do véu do século 21
a torre de babel que é a nossa casa que
saibamos quer não
e desses dois momentos vou falar em em
particular sobre dois tipos de imagem
imaginação a imaginação de um fóbico bió
fóbica ea imaginação de off o be o que é
isso de definição da imaginação de um
fábrica rápida e sucinta a imaginação
bill fóbica também era a vida querer
destruir a vida fazer com que as
palavras que saem do nosso corpo da
nossa boca levem já à nascença capa
certo e arma a imaginação biofábrica e
infectar a vida com epidemias do nada
a imaginação de off lá
amar a vida querer sustentar o mundo
com a palavra o rio ganges diamante
circundar a vida com a nossa forma de
mais justiça e mais liberdade que era o
pai carlos vizinhos meus desta torre de
babel que nos albergue a todos
estou hoje aqui convosco ao longo dos
poetas de antónio vai declamar e
proclamar não com verdades absolutas
nem com certeza definitivas vende-se
obrar convosco léxico profundo da nossa
humanidade comum os 5 verbos que norteia
o nosso sentir o nosso pensar a nossa
pedagogia eo nosso desejo norte temos
vindo a cultivar ao longo desta
entrevista
uma travessia pela vida e pelo tempo que
nos foi dado apitar escutar e dialogar
transformar a mari resistir
estou hoje é que diante do voto
quer por cama proclamar portanto não com
visões do mundo o nosso doravante sinal
de progresso inevitável o mundo dotado
de verdades absolutas observadas
definitivas
o mundo de verdade os monolíticas meus
caros vizinhos e de certezas inabaláveis
é um mundo do mate qo moribundo
arrogantes estudo o mundo assim então
supostamente perfeito é o mundo não é
perfeito mas sim terminal show hoje
dentro vossa querer elogiar portanto o
inacabado é incerto o oposto dos
verdadeiros magnéticas e das certezas
supostamente absolutas
por isso amamos a tocha do véu imagem
perfeita da nossa humanidade
periclitante
somos criaturas andantes e pensantes
somos criaturas mistas essencialmente
inacabadas somos animais livros e
cativos
ao mesmo tempo somos animais finitos na
nossa animale nada somos animais
infinitos na nossa capacidade de
questionar indagar de inventar perguntas
para as quais nem a resposta possível ou
à vista a vida em uma pergunta
somos nós que encarnamos as respostas
provisórias
somos portanto travessia e em simultâneo
séries em queda livre
somos o questionamento e busca somos
sinceros que era ninguém
bordados e em simultâneo destroem mundo
iremos discutir novamente a nossa torna
vanzella uma construção periclitante
instável infinitamente problemática
infinitamente necessária para algum dia
aprendemos a viver e conviver e conhecer
e amar
desejamos ver dinheiro hoje entre nós
uma toca do velo realmente comum pois
damos conta do que pertencermos como
criaturas biológicas e criaturas bélicas
a um destino por ao mas sobretudo comum
estão hoje dentro do vós caros vizinhos
desta troca do governo infinity que nos
albergues
veja se está ainda em construção e já em
ruínas também estou hoje diante do voz
para partilhar convosco a nossa visão de
motor cheio de portas e janelas de
galerias e as cadeirinhas de miradouros
e observatórios de andares de luxo a
partir da qual se iríamos observadores e
vizinhos de algum gante criadores de
novos andares do ator
o my thor de velhos reflexo da nossa
infinita e dela diversidade
agora o grande ditador chaco em 1940 é
um filme de 1940 dobbs ver o contexto
histórico
mas o discurso a imaginação biofábrica
ea imaginação e off ou embora sempre
historicamente condicionadas também são
intemporais o óbvio é intemporal
o fanatismo é intemporal viver - a quem
de nós próprios é intemporal é um
desafio nosso pela história da
humanidade
sendo assim achei por bem criar o
próprio um discurso ao mundo da noite em
tel
agora o filme de chan hol mas para 2016
vou tentar ensinar é custo é venenoso
custou não ler
estou muito custo para gostar de ler
gosto muito de escrever mas lendo um
discurso odioso fanático arrogantes
monolítico é também serve para eu e nós
criarmos anticorpos precisamente o
veneno que representa força vamos sentar
qual rei passou a ler a minha história
o discurso do foco
a minha história é cômoda muitos de nós
é uma história de luta e reconquista do
sonho e de realização
não achei parecer fraco na china para
realizar o meu sonho para realizar o
vosso sonho não na china para apenas
desejar que as coisas acontecem
nash para comandar uma cidadania
mobilizado para conquistar a grandeza
convosco vivemos irmãos e irmãs num
período de grande decadência o nosso
país já usou hoje em dia no estado
profundamente declarante o nosso país as
hoje em dia no estado profundamente
decadente sim
trata se de um estado de dependência que
os tempos colegas nossos exceto ceder
aos nossos que não merecem ser impuseram
a todos nós
nós que somos crentes em deus e fiéis a
grandeza da nossa nação é hora de
recuperar alguns o que esses traidores
que se agachando som das sombras nos
roubaram a grandeza a riqueza à força o
legião os valores ea moral diante de vós
aqui e agora garante o poder restituir a
nosso país a sua antiga grandeza
peço humildemente após ajuda pois todos
acreditamos pergunta ter os elementos
nas mesmas coisas
estamos agora unidos porque só unidos
sob a mesma bandeira com os meios mais
crianças e com o mesmo efeito
iremos vencer o mal que conspira
incessantemente contra nós que fora quer
dentro do nosso país
vamos deitar fora este lixo como sairmos
então vitoriosos deste marasmo desta de
querência desta perda de confiança desta
agressão contra a pureza da nossa nação
contra a grandeza do nosso caráter
contra a supremacia do nosso país
digo vos é simples
o meu programa é simples é simples sim
embora exija exigirá de nós grandes
sacrifícios no futuro
sabeis que tenho razão pois a minha
razão é a vossa o farei ao ser possuída
é simples
mandei para fora todos os nossos
inimigos
mandei-lhe legalizar tudo o que hoje em
dia com os pública a nassau ea nossa fé
tudo é eliminar as limpar e ranchito
hirai a grandeza do nosso país estará
novamente conosco caros compatriotas
tenham lutado muito tenho lutado muito
para realizar o meu sonho que também o
vosso sonho e me agora diante de vós o
vosso irmão
ciente do vosso mal estágio da nossa
tristeza das nossas preocupações
conheço somos únicos que somos unidos
digo-vos o nosso deus está conosco
nós temos outra imaginação não temos a
imaginação de off que a minha vida que
há um ou outro que vem no outro o seu
próprio espelho e se prolonga por creche
que ama que compreenda com compaixão e
agora portanto para concluir e como que
para contrariar o veneno be o foco do
discurso prévio tão tóxico do seu
fanatismo e tão mortífero nas suas
listas visões absolutas e terminais
proclamamos aqui o seguinte discurso
como força verdão começou seu discurso
final do partido judeu do mesmo filme do
chaco a proclamar com a sua imaginação
bió fifa o amor à vida ao mundo testar
ainda à nossa espera
o viram talvez alguns laivos do
manifesto futurista dalva de campos 917
do único número da revista portugal fifa
é futurista é um dos grandes testes do
século 20
fran pessoa pai e mãe todos nós nos
botou um discurso abriu o discurso é de
ópio
produtos preâmbulo em nome de uma errada
dirigimo-nos aos fanáticos desta terra
conseguinte manifesto de carla
declaramos e que que desconfiamos da
ordem da estabilidade o ditador fanático
promete chairá sangue e dor
desconfiamos que queimasse fisicamente
pasta o ser humano um ser de manawa
desconfiamos do discurso fanático que
prometa ordem mas que mata a mudança a
mudança é uma das rádios da humanidade à
humanidade é capaz da de curiosidade a
abertura humanidade é capaz de
reconhecer apurou lá das suas culturas
ao mesmo tempo que reconheça a
proximidade do todos partilhamos os
mesmos problemas e os mesmos medos a
humanidade é sim capaz de admitir o
outro como espelho desse mesmo a
humanidade é sim capaz de adaptar de
criar e transformar a humanidade é uma
espécie diferenciada mas uma sim a
humanidade é plural a humanidade viver
sua humanidade e também um rock em
progress parecer um ser humano é preciso
marcar o caráter sombra cor o
entendimento sobre a confusão a
comunicação sobre o monólogo o mundo um
mundo é do tamanho das nossas buscas
o mundo é a nossa casa eo nosso
miradouro caros amigos o ato de pensar é
o nosso direito ea nossa aventura
caros amigos aventura do pensar faz do
animal humano um ser de mudança do
crescimento da invenção do discernimento
da compreensão
o amor caros amigos somos seres de
certeza das várias que o chegam ea -
deixam as nossas certezas pertencem a um
tempo menor e terminado mas o fanático o
daia o inacabado mata o inacabado
o fanático torna-se ditador há nesse
mesmo ano seu monólogo seu monólogo traz
palavras blindadas e o seu amor traz
morte
nós é que os podemos sentir para além do
óbvio
o nosso cérebro florest na floresta dos
factos e nas ruas
ebo vários da mente meus caros vizinhos
do ator nobel de hoje em que fu no
humano da vemos de crescer e florescer
a escolha é um monstro liberdade em flor
sentir e pensar juntos inventam o ser
humano e inventa um ser humano como ser
andante pensante como certa factos e de
sonhos como sempre começa os céus como
segurança e descoberta
descobrimos o que placar os vizinhos da
torre de babel que o mundo é do tamanho
novos grandes desta terra mas do tamanho
do sonho de cada um que o mundo é do
tamanho não dos fanatismos e hoje mas do
tamanho das idéias que ainda há um
nascer que o mundo é do tamanho da nossa
capacidade de questionar e criar
temos uma forma maior do que a refeição
que o mundo que já lá está nos terra
descobrimos que o mundo é do tamanho não
da hemorragia do óleo fanático mas do
trabalho da sabedoria e do amor
descobrimos que o mundo não tem só o ras
chefes mas antes e os ritos descobrimos
que para o fanático e de todo o mundo em
um cemitério
descobrimos que o mundo é na verdade na
certa enfim de idéias e de vida
aprendemos que a história da humanidade
está ainda por inventar
aprendemos que a memória não apenas a
chaga do passado mal cicatrizada
não há a maria é um órgão futurista como
temos de viver então neste século que é
de todos os meus caros vizinhos
somos todos vizinhos mas mal sabemos
conviver
somos todos vizinhos mas nós podemos
pensar que somos todos os vizinhos mas o
fanático espreita e o ditador conquista
somos todos vizinhos mas a nossa torre
de babel está uso em ruínas
carlos vizinhos declaramos que nunca é
fácil mas o caminho é simples
declaramos que a história se cumpre não
pensarem nos sentir na compaixão e na
compreensão declaremos que podemos
compreender e amar para além das algemas
das algemas que nos puseram haja tanto
tempo que hoje nem as vemos declaremos
declaramos que compreenderia marlos
pertencem como nos pertencem
o ar e os pulmões declaramos que
compreender e amar são a histórica nos
aguarda
caros amigos e vizinhos caros habitação
está torna do véu caros irmãos e irmãs
do destino comum deste planeta
declararmos que essa história da
compreensão e do amor que nos aguarda
está neste momento entre nós mais do que
isso
já nos convocou e já nos transformou da
bel portugal mundo 17 de junho de 2016